[Music]
nancy
is in los angeles hi nancy how are you
doing how are you better than i deserve
how can we help
um i would like to you know some advice
my son has i have his money parked in a
credit union
he has a hundred dollars on the cd
and he has 530
on a regular savings account and he
would like to know
if i could put a purchase money in a
robinhood app
investing account i want to know your
advice
no he does not need to mess with robin
hood
dangerous as a [ __ ] gun no thank you
if he wants to do some investing that's
fine
uh but it's not about the actual results
500 is not going to give you actual
results it's more about
learning about the investments and so if
he wanted to do a 500
investment in some mutual funds sit down
with a smart vester pro
let them teach him because he's
obviously interested in that kind of
thing
um then uh you know
they they would help him and there are a
few mutual funds you can open for as
little as 500
and um many of them are a thousand or 2
500 but there's a couple of them you can
get in for 500 bucks
but it's not because that's going to
make him a lot of money it's because
it's a teaching
experience for him and he's obviously
got an interest
in that sort of thing truthfully
other than that i would not do it i
would say 500
is a good thing to start towards his car
500 is a good thing to start towards the
insurance on the car he drives
uh 500 is a good thing to start thinking
about college with
those kinds of things rather than
playing around but robin hood's going to
be single stock investing and that's a
really
dumb idea the lesson he's going to learn
here is going to be pain
right and he's only 12 so that's why i
figure i wouldn't do it but i wanted
your advice i
would i kind of already you know you
were gonna say no
yeah absolutely so again if he wants to
sit down at 12 years old with a smart
vester pro
that's fine from a learning perspective
but really it's going to get fairly
boring fairly fast
once he makes the investment because
mutual funds don't they're not something
you look at every day
they don't go up and down there's not a
lot of action
uh it's um it's a little bit boring
really good investing is
what do you tell somebody dave who's how
to find that balance between teaching a
12 year old or a 13 or 14 year old about
there's a couple of of goals to save
towards and
enjoying money like you worked hard to
mow a couple of lawns
um you need to give some of that away
you need to save some of that
what's that balance well i mean you can
decide the the balance but the
the balance has to be that there is some
meaning that that
uh if you only save or you only give
or you just blow it like or you only
that's just misbehaving okay and so the
goal here when you're talking about
teaching kids about money
is not the actual results of the 500
it's not that if the kid takes 50 of
that and blows it on something stupid
uh the goal is it doesn't damage his
life permanently from a math
standpoint but if he doesn't learn the
lesson
from having done something stupid with
the money then that sets a pattern up
that he's still doing or she's still
doing when they're 35
that's exactly right and so we're going
to spend
and i'm going to let you do something
dumb i'm going to tell you that you know
if you if you'll save up a little more
you can get a toy that will last
or you can buy the cheap one that'll be
broken by friday
right and it but i gotta have it okay
then when it breaks friday i do say i
told you so
okay because i want you to learn the
lesson now remember when dad and you
talked about this and i said this is
going to be the result
so now your whole doc all the money you
spend on that toy is gone now
because you bought the cheap one and it
broke and we talked about this and i'm
not brow beating them or shaming them i
want to make sure the lesson lanes they
see that a plus b
equals c i want to i'm going to say this
is what this is the result
of your actions because my goal is to
teach them to work
to give to save and to spend wisely
before they leave home and then there's
a high probability they can stay gone
this is the goal